americans held hostage behind enemy
lines
day 67
70 days since joe promised that he would
not abandon americans 67 days since he
did abandon our fellow citizens they are
still not home our friends family
thousands of green card holders are
allies family members none of them are
safe none of them are secure many
reports of people being beaten and
murdered back at home our southern
border that's never been worse also
preventable
our economy is in shambles you look at
energy prices they are now through the
roof
now we are begging russia and opec for
more oil our reliance on foreign oil is
back our supply chain predictably
preventable in a state of chaos russia
and china they are emboldened like never
before and they are on the move and
despite inheriting three vaccines and
the therapeutic known as monoclonal
antibody treatments
met more people have died from covert 19
this year under joe biden than in 2020
under donald trump and remember i'm
going to get this under control and and
you can go celebrate the 4th of july and
maybe now you won't be able to celebrate
christmas now with a new more lethal
delta variant on the way i don't know
we'll call it the brandon variant uh it
could get even worse
these variants get worse and worse more
on this in a moment but clearly tonight
because joe biden the sad truth is that
the united states of america the country
we all love is now and i wish i never
had to report this it is a precipitous
it is a dangerous state of decline
we do have good news we can solve this
we can fix this we can save the american
people for example that joe biden
abandoned in afghanistan we can
permanently reinstate donald trump's
state of mexico policy other trump
border policies like resuming
construction of the southern border wall
and we can go back to energy
independence finish the keystone
pipeline we can drill for oil gas in
texas oklahoma alaska north dakota
instead of begging opec and getting
energy from russia
the bad news is sadly none of this is
going to happen with joe biden and the
radical new green deal socialists in
power i don't know maybe we could just
call them president carter ii or
president brandon if you like he caused
each and every one of these crisis they
were all preventable and with each
passing day his administration's
policies and proposals are only making
everything worse and sadly it's not even
clear that biden even really knows
what's going on and today during what
was another typical rambling bizarre
speech this one in scranton pennsylvania
well once again biden the cognitive mess
that he is is cognitive decline more
obvious than ever you decide
grant is where i played shortstop at the
grimmie's little league in the first
year that it was put up my dad helped
build the field down there
and spent a lot of time at s at semi's
uh buying penny candy
and hank's hoagies on woodlawn street uh
watching movies of the roosie i was the
only kid in my in my ear that i was able
to walk across the lackey on that pipe
that was just above the thing
and my dad had moved from wilmington
delaware to scranton when he was a
senior in high school junior in high
school he went then was called saint
thomas not the prep but it's called
saint thomas in those days
that's saint paul so you know i
my nickname was uh
blackbird i wasn't very big but
you could beat me but i'd hurt you
god save this country did you understand
that joey was supposed to be selling his
build back better new green deal social
spending bill clearly he got um a little
sidetracked as usual and since joe is
not able to articulate the details of
this massive spending bill we will for
him build back new green deals socialism
better will wreck the economy for
decades to come it has nothing to do
with real infrastructure like roads and
bridges and tunnels instead it will
raise taxes on everyone in spite of what
they're telling you especially people
making under fifty thousand dollars a
year they are already being
disproportionately impacted by biden's
horrific energy and economic policies
this build back better new green deal
socialism would allow the irs to spy on
your bank account it'll add trillions to
our debt and deficit as they continue to
lie to us and tell us it won't cost us a
penny it will wreck and destroy our oil
and gas and energy industries it will
waste billions and billions of dollars
on new green deals socialist
projects probably worse than solyndra it
will fund their cradle to grave womb to
the tomb socialist entitlement to for
people to choose not to work that's not
going to work out well it passed this
new green deal build back better madness
will cause inflation to continue to
skyrocket at a time when inflation is
already out of control near a 30-year
high i mean that's that's where we are
today median income households are now
spending it on average an extra 175
dollars a month on just food and fuel
and housing that's two thousand one
hundred dollars a year in a biden
inflation tax have you been in the
grocery store lately well twelve pack of
pepsi is nearly doubled the cost of
pringles you like potato chips they're
up you like milk for your kids that's up
the cost of chicken beef is up proctor
and gamble announcing even more price
increases for a whole range of products
from toothpaste to laundry detergent
paper towels diapers toilet paper if you
can find it the prices are going up and
p g expects to spend an extra 2.1
billion dollars on transportation so
they can even get their products to
market and as we predicted those costs
all of them every penny will be passed
on to you the american people you the
consumer that is if you can even find
what you need in stock there are empty
shelves now all across the country we
have stores now rationing products light
paper towels and toilet paper i don't
know why is there the mad dash for
toilet paper but according to ron klein
these are what he calls high class
problems the washington post that wants
us to stop complaining and to lower our
expectations that when we go to a store
we'll be able to get what we want gee we
have such a high bar we're asking for
here a top biden advisor is telling all
of us we need to make sacrifices we meet
may need to accept that we may not be
able to get the jacket that we want in
15 colors that we want but we'll get a
jacket jen soccer he is calling it the
tragedy oh your treadmill didn't arrive
on time instead of looking for solutions
to the many serious crisis all of them
have caused the bidet administration
their defenders they'd rather lie and
mock the very real concerns of millions
of americans the people they have hurt
the most middle class americans and
those americans that are poor and
struggling already they can't afford the
high cost of everything going up they
can't afford to pay more to heat and
cool their homes and fill their gas
tanks joe biden caused all of it all of
it can be prevented and all of it can be
stopped tomorrow just go back to the
trump policies that worked take a look
do you believe that right now there's a
crisis at the border i think that the
the answer is no as individuals come
across the border
and
they are both assessed for whether they
have any symptoms if they have symptoms
they are the intention is for them to be
quarantined that is our process they're
not intending to stay here for a lengthy
period of time why is the administration
flying thousands of migrants from the
border to florida and new york in the
middle of the night
uh well i'm not sure that's in the
middle of the night but let me tell you
what's happening here um
it is our 4 29 a.m well very early in
the morning here we are and best of all
the cost of these bills in terms of
adding to the deficit is zero
zero
zero well i think there's always been
two kinds of christmas shoppers there's
the ones who have all their list
completed by halloween and then there's
people like me who show up at the mall
on christmas eve if you're in that
ladder bucket obviously there's going to
be more challenges
people couldn't get dishwashers and
furniture and treadmills delivered on
time not to mention all sorts of other
things so why is the tragedy of the
short the treadmill that's delayed
oh really that's supposed to be funny
maybe somebody wants a treadmill by the
way 3.5 trillion will cost zero zero
zero joe says okay and those uh 2 a.m
and 4 a.m flights they're not middle of
the night that when they're flying
illegal immigrants into states and
cities without telling anybody no that
would be an early morning flight
you see what they're saying under the
biden administration you need to accept
that our lives will be worse and you
need to stop complaining we all need to
stop complaining we all need to get in
line it's really not that different
remember jimmy carter some of you may
not remember told us oh lower your
thermostat and put on a sweater and make
modest sacrifices and start living
thriftly because the energy crisis would
never get better that's what he told us
you might remember this
we must face the fact
that the energy shortage is permanent
there is no way we can solve it quickly
but if we all cooperate and make modest
sacrifices
if we learn to live thriftly and
remember the importance of helping our
neighbors then we can find ways to
adjust and to make our society more
efficient
and our own lives more enjoyable
and productive simply by keeping our
thermostats for instance at 65 degrees
in the daytime
and 55 degrees at night we could save
half the current shortage of natural gas
yeah the tragedy of the treadmill and
you should shop for your christmas
presents in october if you have any hope
of
your kids being happy with santa this
year the more things change the more
they stay the same now a labor shortage
is driving many of our supply chain woes
and that's only going to get worse why
joe's vaccine mandate we've talked about
this this is no longer a discussion
about the vax or not to vacs we have
discussed that over and over again you
know my position take it seriously learn
study ask serious questions look at your
own health condition
get your unique medical history talk to
your doctor doctors i believe in the
science i believe in the science of
vaccination i'm not your doctor i'm not
telling anybody what to do i've
encouraged you all to take it seriously
i've seen the worst of it i've
encouraged all my viewers consult with
your doctor and then choose the best
course of action but i also believe in
freedom and liberty i also believe in
medical privacy and i also believe in
patient client uh doctor patient
confidentiality i've encouraged all of
you to get informed so you can ask great
questions of your doctors about oh what
if you have a breakthrough case so you
didn't get the vaccine and you got a
posit a positive cova test what do you
do next first question i would ask my
doctor is uh what do you know about
monoclonal antibodies okay
he might tell you about regeneron and
the infusion and how critical it is to
get it as early as possible but i'm not
a medical professional i'm not going to
give you medical advice nor should any
of these people with their one size fits
all medicine either at this point pretty
much everyone in this country has made
up their minds about the vaccine i don't
think many minds are going to be changed
at this point the debate for many people
is over millions of americans they're
now actually
willing and ready to give up their jobs
their salaries their pensions their
careers because they don't agree with
the mandate it's happening already the
chicago police their police force could
be down a thousand officers
and we know about the violence in
chicago we may lose thousands if not
tens of thousands of military personnel
they may quit or face hefty fines that
they're not going to be able to pay
teachers are not going to get it and
we're going to have a shortage of
teachers and cops and military and
firefighters and first responders and
all those nurses and and health care
workers that went into work in the
middle of the worst of covid and risked
their lives to save other people's lives
many that got covered themselves they
dove on one covert grenade you know a
minute after another they worked in a
covert petri ditch dish now we're going
to fire them
you know longer response times for 9 11
that would be a result rising crime that
would be a result waiting health care
shortages that would be a reality now
ask yourself if that really is making
america a better or safer place of
course not instead of vilifying half of
america and making the labor shortage
worse the biden administration maybe
should be focused on educating the
country if you have a breakthrough case
what do you ask your doctor ask about
monoclonal antibodies for example
that's one according to the new england
journal of medicine in the unc school of
medicine monoclonal antibodies are
effective in disrupting the progression
of coven 19 and reduced death joey only
mentioned them one time maybe should
talk about it more then he rationed it
because governor desantis set up these
monoclonal antibody centers all
throughout the state of florida once the
delta variant started showing all these
breakthrough cases the biden
administration almost never mentions
this treatment how about an option if
people are that
against the vaccination why not test
them every day and employees accommodate
them and respect the fact that they
might have a different point of view you
know they would rather demonize
americans over this for democrats
everything's political one size fits all
all of us will pay a price and this will
impact our economy look at this fox news
poll nearly 60 percent of americans
disapprove of joe biden's handling of
the economy already they disapprove of
his policies on immigration and border
security and foreign policy and taxes
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else